Hey!
Congrats.
Yeah, thanks.
Cheers.
Yeah.
I mean, bummers.
Bummers.
How are us to sell them?
You don't even dump shit like this.
Hey, that's hot.
Yeah, that.
Cast a spell. Cast a spell.
I'm like, how does this feel?
It's longer than I think it is.
Boo-brah-da-nooom.
Last verse.
We're going to check out some bongos.
But you know what?
That's what we're going to do.
We're going to check out some bongos.
Not bad.
That is not bad.
But I'm always, I'm like Ben on the hunt for seconds of furniture.
I'm just kidding.
The Lord has blessed us with a water mask.
Why is it?
Alright, who casted a freezing spell?
The wench throws the axe.
It's cold.
It's still cold.
.
So I was like, this is not a should have been.